we're in the beginning of what appears
to be a great technological upset but
some say this has happened before the
classic historical example of a
technological disruption that most
people would point to is what happened
in agriculture it used to be that half
or more of the people in the United
States worked on farms now it may be one
or two percent of our workforce is
directly engaged in agriculture so there
was a huge disruption there the
disruption was tools like the tractor
and the combine modern equipment speeds
up the wood makes it easier and more
efficient too and it hasn't stopped
we've always made machines that made us
people better right today a farmer can
plow the fields for 150 hungry people
and barely has to lift a finger to do so
machines increasingly equipped with
sophisticated machine vision and
artificial intelligence now plant weed
and harvest an ever-growing array of
crops and it isn't just the field work
that's being disrupted today robots are
prepping cooking and even serving us
tasks that until recently when your
human could be fair
[Music]
so when we hear the sound of the Bell we
know that a new order needs to be
prepared fire was raining at zoom Pizza
it's all about the fresh ingredients and
the robots and now Marc is gonna spread
that sauce and we want her to spread the
sauce evenly but not too evenly because
we still want to have that artisan feel
Marta isn't your typical line cook it's
an industrial robotic arm modified to
spread Pizza sausage just so at zoom
humans and robots work together to make
pizza the robots do the tasks that are
repetitive that are boring that are
unsafe like sticking your hand in and
out of an 800 degree oven Colin says
thanks in part to the robots only 9
percent of zooms operating cost goes to
labor a typical pizza restaurant might
spend 25% on workers but zoom insists
it's not out to replace people with
robots humans do the tasks that are
human centered like cooking from scratch
preparing fresh produce making sauce and
so this is how we're able to unlock
human potential to give people better
more satisfying jobs and how we're also
able to reduce some of our hourly labor
costs so we can spend more money on
high-quality ingredients for our
customers but to some employers robots
could be the perfect burger flippers as
fast-food workers demand higher pay last
year then CEO of Carl's jr. and opposed
des who was briefly president Trump's
Labor Secretary Peck told Business
Insider that automation might be a way
to counter a rising minimum wage there
is no need or requirement for automation
to replace jobs or reduce wages or in
any way hurt human beings the problem
exists when the industry attempts to use
automation as an excuse or justification
to drive down wages for workers somehow
to pit robots and humans against each
other or to suggest that policy to
is the minimum wage is wrongheaded
because it necessarily results in
automation which we have just not seen
to be the case the closer to the ground
many farmers see automation as an
absolute necessity as agricultural labor
shortages loom we've got an aging
workforce so people who are coming out
to do agricultural work we're not
getting that younger population into the
job planning head for the future it's
important that we're ready to have fewer
workers crops like corn and wheat have
been automated for decades new robotics
are now being developed to do the often
back-breaking work of fruit and
vegetable farming take this automated
lettuce harvester at Taylor farms the
idea around this equipment really take
the hardest part of the job out who's
the bending over and picking the lettuce
and so the automated harvester allows us
to use water knifes to pull the product
off the bed tops and bring it up to a
table where then it's inspected by human
beings today the harvester reduces
lettuce peaking labor needs by half I
think we're always moving down an
automation track I don't know if you get
the full automation there's a science
around agriculture but there's a bit of
an art to it as well but I think in
terms of getting rid of the hardest part
of the jobs I see that continuing to
flow another California robotics company
is taking on even more difficult and
delicate harvesting picking fruit so the
advantage that people have over a robot
is just the ability to do this task at
all it's never been possible before for
a robot to recognize fruit and pick it
without damaging the fruit or without
damaging the tree but this prototype
robot harvester uses cutting-edge
machine vision and artificial
intelligence to precisely pluck apples
from the tree our machine goes down an
apple or tree road takes lots of
pictures of the apple canopy and
artificial intelligence is used to
recognize those apples and find out
where they are in the space and then we
use automation on the manipulation side
to go and pick those apples off of the
tree
this machine was developed for the US
Apple industry which has also struggled
with labor shortages it could be
deployed in orchards as soon as the fall
of 2018 we're just beginning to inch
closer and closer to what people can do
in both vision and robotic manipulator
as they advance expect to see more
robots making meals possible we're
cooking from the heart we're cooking
from that place in us that's very human
so it's never our desire to look at
automation as a way to completely change
that entire process we use automation in
the places where robots are better than
humans but there are many places where
humans are better than robots robots
can't go to my local produce farmer and
talk to him about what's coming into
season at least not yet still zoom is
already making room for a new bot one
that will pull the hot pies from the
oven